we have different statements here that
can each be expressed as an algebraic
expression and as you might have guessed
i would love you to pause this video and
try to write each of these statements as
an algebraic expression before we do it
together
all right now let's work on it together
so this first statement we have 2
less than x
so my brain thinks all right let me
start with x and how am i going to get 2
less than that well i'm going to
subtract 2.
and this is an interesting example
because you see the order that we see it
in the sentence is not the order that we
would necessarily write it in the
expression right over here very
important to think about what is going
on here what is being described
now this next statement why fewer than
three
well we in my mind i'm going to start
with three and i'm going to be y fewer
than that so i'm going to start with 3
and then i'm going to be y
fewer than that
now these first two statements are
similar in that you have something less
than something else or something fewer
than something else they just swapped
the number and the variable
now this third statement
x decreased by five
so my mind is thinking what am i
starting with i'm starting with an x
and i'm decreasing it by five so i could
view that as minus 5 or i'm going to
take a 5 away from it